Malaysia's Prime Minister Mahathir
Mohamad has offered his resignation to
the king and his political party has
quit the ruling coalition that follows
talks by some ruling coalition members
and opposition and groups on forming a
new government that would exclude the
prime minister's chosen successor
Lawrence lui is in Kuala Lumpur says
it's unclear what matters next move will
be the statement from the Prime
Minister's Office confirming that Mohave
had indeed tendered a love letter of
resignation to the king while there was
no reason given for the resignation but
we've since heard the finance minister
coming out and saying that Mohave
attended his resignation because he did
not want you do not want the party to
have to work with I'm not now I'm no is
the parties that was in power in
Malaysia for decades it had ruled
Malaysia since the country gained
independence from British in 1957 and it
was only al stirred in the last general
election in 2018 its leader was its
former leader was the former prime
minister of this country Najib Razak
who's been accused or who's been charged
and is on trial for corruption he's been
accused of stealing billions of dollars
from a state investment fund now we're
not sure whether the King has accepted
the resignation letter from Mahathir
Mohamad but many constitutional experts
say the king because his role is largely
ceremonial he has no choice but to
accept the resignation it's also not
clear what's going to happen next
did Mahathir asked the king to hold to
dissolve Parliament and announce fresh
elections
well we haven't heard anything on that
front yet but according to the
Constitution the person who will become
Prime Minister in this country is
someone who commands the confidence of
Parliament now if all things had
remained the same then this person could
take could well have been Anwar Ibrahim
but because Maha third party has left
the ruling coalition and because some
members of our Noirs party have also
either resigned or been sacked from the
party Anwar it's doubtful that Anwar
will have the numbers to actually back
him to be the next prime minister of
this country so it's very unclear what's
going to happen next